well the Bill of Rights is a stumbling
block on the way to shutting down speech
that the left doesn't like at least in
government but there's a new avenue for
those who would like to censor what you
say and think and that's corporations
the Left have wised up to this if you
want to stop someone from telling the
truth
use companies to do it the social media
Giants and they are so far the most
prominent casualty of the crusade
against free expression has been the
radio show host Alex Jones but are we
smart to think censorship will stop with
him Marc Penn is a former adviser to
Bill Clinton he is a liberal who still
believes in the free exchange of ideas
and he joins us tonight so thank you
mark for coming on so I'm fascinated by
the Alex Jones story because because it
was Alex Jones almost no conservatives
rose to his defense because idea was
what Alex Jones yuck but it's not really
about Alex Jones is it it's about the
idea that companies can make it
impossible for your voice to be heard is
that a precedent we should be
comfortable with well I I really think
you have to be worried about big tech
becoming Big Brother yes because this
used to be neutral platforms that said
we're open to free expression that's our
core value and now they've said well not
so much with particularly Facebook
hiring 10,000 new sensors on top of
another 10,000 and having roving
censoring BOTS looking for content look
I never read Alex Jones but here's
somebody with millions of followers
publicly accountable for his speech
operating within Supreme Court standards
yanked from the media that's a surprise
to me that says that these platforms are
no longer as open as they presented
themselves to be and it said it's not
just him they're there many like him
who've been yanked lesser-known
but still so this has political
implications you ran in manage campaigns
for so long he this must have occurred a
lot of our political debate takes place
on social media platforms so if they
clamp down on one side of the debate why
wouldn't that influence in elections
outcome
well obviously could have a big
influence on elections increasingly
because where people turn for their news
is that they look at the news feeds that
are run by the major social media
companies
and so they're more powerful than any TV
station more powerful than Fox yes
because of the amount of time that
people spent and it's a funnel so if
you're not at the top you don't get seen
and so in the past they had some neutral
ways of doing this but now they've
increasingly applied still more
mysterious algorithms plus individual
sensors and remember there are private
platforms they say so they're not
they're not actually subject to the
First Amendment unless we get some
legislation here that says free speech
is an Internet right it's totally
meaningless if I owned a toll road I
can't say anyone of a certain race can
drive on my toll road and so they're not
actually fully private companies we have
a public interest I would say in keeping
them free and open
why aren't if you cared about the
integrity of our elections why isn't
Congress acting I don't know why
Congress isn't acting part of it is
because to stand up to a social media
company means you could have five
million people on your doorstep the next
day so I think there's been a lot of
intimidation in Congress instead of
bipartisan agreement that hey we cannot
have this kind of regulation of speech
where whoever runs one of the big
platforms can pick out speech which
speech goes in which piece doesn't not
when they've been exempted from the
libel laws when they've been set up as
open platforms and they now become media
companies instead and that's exactly
what's happened they become media
companies that take ads on the media
that they run and they have editors and
algorithms and BOTS that run it I really
believe the ten years from now this
segment what you just said will be seen
as as pression I mean I think it's a big
story that's being ignored by virtually
everyone for reasons I don't fully
understand maybe you're right it's
cowardice but it shouldn't be mark Penn
thank you for that thank you